one of the most important things you can
look for is the culture of the place
you're going to join culture really
matters culture has to do with values
and in my years in the valley I've seen
there's companies with really cultures
that appeal to me and others that do not
I don't want to make a judgement about
these but just to have you be tuned up
for them my partner a me Randy Komisar
wrote a book
he teaches over at the engineering
school called the monk in the riddle a
great book for you read about Lennie in
his startup venture funerals calm but he
contrasts the difference between
mercenaries and missionaries and the the
difference is really very profound the
mercenary cultures are quite driven and
paranoia is kind of at the heart of what
drives them I would frequently have
arguments with Andy Grove Andy wood says
only the paranoid survive and I'd say he
entity paranoid is disease state you
know that that may not be the best way
to motivate because instead of paranoia
you can have passion for what you're
doing paranoia pushes you forward
passion draws you into an opportunity
it's the difference between
opportunistic and being strategic or the
difference between the difference
between mercenaries and missionaries is
the difference between the pitch and the
deal or forming a real partnership this
difference can be seen in the time view
that you have is this venture on a
sprint to go build the next Instagram as
fast as we can are we going to take a
very long view the way Jeff Bezos does
at amazon.com I'm not judging one of the
other is right or wrong but it's an
important dimension are you going to
obsess on the competition or obsess on
the customers are you going to set up
the culture so there's a kind of
aristocracy of the founders who really
call all the shots or do you want a
meritocracy we can get that all the
ideas on the table have the best ideas
when it's a difference between focusing
on the financial statements or the value
statements I think it's the difference
between whether or not you're in a
culture where there's a lot of loners in
your
on your own or there's a real emphasis
on mentoring coaching so that the whole
team gets better
I think it's insurance between an
attitude of entitlement which I find
unappealing or the hewlett-packard idea
that people go there they make a
contribution that's recognized and that
makes everybody more effective you know
in Randy's book he calls it the
difference between the deferred life
plan and a whole life one that really
works my take on this is it's a
difference between a lust for making
money and a lust for making meaning as
well as money in any entrepreneur that
comes to tell us that they're not
interested in making money these are the
enterprise for-profit entrepreneurs I
usually don't believe them but I think
you can achieve success and significance
not just focus on success by choosing
what it is that you choose to do